relatives of those on board broke down
in tears after bodies and wreckage were
found they've been waiting for news at
Surabaya airport for three desperate
days since the plane disappeared the
Indonesian president visited them at the
crisis center there that Buddha prathap
and I feel deep loss over this disaster
and pray for the families to be given
the strength to face up to it rescuers
located and recovered 40 victims before
nightfall this helicopter crew winched
up one body from the water more and more
pieces of debris have been found an
emergency slide lifejackets what could
be an aircraft door
the wreckage was found 160 kilometers
southwest of bangkalan boon in the
Indonesian province of kalimantan on the
island of Borneo that's just 10
kilometers from where the plane lost
contact on Sunday rescuers have also
started bringing wreckage from the crash
site back to land Tim bizarreness to
onda I can confirm that's the area where
the plane crashed a flower and with an
indonesian air force Hercules has also
spotted an underwater object it looks
like an airplane and by the water in the
area is only 60 meters deep ships are on
their way to help in the search for
bodies and the wreck of the plane one
priority is the recovery of the black
box flight recorders which may provide
the information on why the plane came
down